let's take a look at the first story of
this op-ed from joe koncha over at the
hill
he says biden's poor tv ratings against
trump is exactly what this
administration wants
i don't agree but the point joe is
making is
i believe it's a fair point though i do
disagree he basically says you know we
know that trump was just desperate for
ratings and he was well he didn't say
desperate but like bragging about how
good his ratings were
then we see joe biden his ratings are in
the gutter nobody wants to watch the guy
nobody wants to watch cnn or msnbc
because they built a network on hating
trump and binding just ain't it
but he goes on to mention that with all
this massive spending he says
1.9 trillion for coveted relief 2.25
trillion in infrastructure
with nobody paying attention to what
biden's doing he can just
keep doing these things and no one will
stop him i don't like the argument
because who is going to stop him anyway
mitch mcconnell he's not going to do
anything
and all they really need the democrats
for is the rage vote
and then like clockwork the traditional
liberals go back to sleep i experienced
it in 2008
we're watching it happen now this is
good news for disaffected liberals
moderates conservatives trump supporters
and whoever else on the right
because this means that with liberals
going to sleep declaring victory but
only on a
very very slim victory well the
republicans in 2022 will likely
take the house and maybe even in 2024
we'll see what happens
but uh i wonder what y'all think about
joe biden's
inability to make anybody care about
what he's doing i think it's actually
really interesting
i think we saw a bunch of that after the
election right for
there were like two weeks where it
seemed like we were just all gonna
celebrate
um biden's victory that the country was
going to open up it seemed like that was
the
deal that was being made that the nation
was being held hostage to a bind victory
and then you know sure enough they came
crashing back down and
locking everything up again um which
actually seemed way worse than the first
time
uh but i do think that liberals have uh
pretty well gone to sleep because they
figure that they've got their guy in
their guy is going to do the right thing
and that's that they were so invested in
hating trump
that anything that's not trump they
think is good and so they're not
actually applying any
critical thinking power to these
policies that are being enacted
they're not looking at what horror it's
going to
implement in the u.s i wonder if they
ever actually cared at all you know i
know i know people who have no business
being in politics
like people who sure who didn't vote no
8 12
or 16 who all of a sudden were like
filming videos of themselves where
they're like i gotta put my ballot
they're like are you doing your duty
with your ballot and i'm like dude
you have no idea what you're talking
about you're just doing this because the
guy in the tv said to do it is that is
that really it's tribal
so after that trend what's the next
trendy thing to do it certainly is not
joe biden no one cares about him no one
cares about joe biden but i do think
it's interesting too
we had in the fall we had aoc we had
bernie sanders and other progressives
complaining that joe biden wasn't going
to be far left enough that he wasn't
going to
install the progressive agenda and now
we're seeing them basically
celebrating you have hillary clinton
saying he's doing a bang-up job you have
aoc
saying that he's really being much more
collaborative with progressives
and i think that the conservatives that
um
held their nose and voted for joe biden
i think they were played
you know they believed that joe biden
was was just going to be
ineffectual um you had bill crystal
talking about how this was going to be
the way to
install and create a new conservatism
that all of this stuff was going to be
easier for conservatives with trump out
of the way and instead they were
completely steamrolled you know it was
like a total bait and switch
they voted for a moderate guy who wasn't
going to do anything
and instead they got this progressive
guy who's just
spending all the money and then some but
like
he's still not progressive enough for
the actual socialists
well aoc seems happy about him so far
she said the other day
before his his uh his state of the union
there
well you know does aoc actually have
principles or is
she just like a stop she she's like a um
of pressure relief valve for the
democratic party yeah in the event
the woke left becomes too disaffected
she then goes like
and they're like oh we're satisfied
again so
yeah i'm not sure if she has any
principles she goes on for long periods
of time on instagram live
and we can try and sort it out although
uh so much of it seems like
just straight nonsense there are rumors
that because new york is losing a
district they're going to get rid of
hers
have you heard that i have heard that is
that but is that true or is that just
i don't know i mean people thinking
whoever's in charge would get to re
redraw the districts and the democrats
are in charge so they could redraw the
district
and they could draw out a republican
district instead
right yeah that makes way more sense i
mean aoc has fallen in line
she's she like i said she's the stop
she's a pressure release valve for
for the democratic party the
progressives get too angry she comes in
and she does her you know finger snap
and then acts like
nancy pelosi should get votes and then
votes for nancy pelosi while pretending
like she doesn't like nancy pelosi
she gets her whole crew on board i don't
think joe biden is
a socialist the socialists the actual
like you know bernie
dsa types think joe biden is a fascist
just not as much of a fascist as trump
and i'm like
okay maybe you know whatever i'm
sure joe biden is not a good guy he's
corrupt he's crooked he's pro-war all
these really awful things
so sure i guess i'll give him that one
but to say he's not enacting far-left
policies
when he's just like money printer gober
just cranking out yeah he's very clearly
yes he very
clearly he rescinded the executive
orders on critical race theory
he sure did and now they have a new
thing going through
to more like mandate critical race
theory
in school oh that's right yeah and
that's pretty weird and you had you
i'm sorry i'm sorry you mean to teach
black history uh no
no no reuters reuters says it's about
teaching black history
we have black history black history is
essential the civil rights movement is
of course
monumental achievement in american
history um but that's not what they're
talking about they're talking about like
you mean reuters lied to me did you see
the headline from reuters i'm not going
to say that i don't want to get
fact-checked
reuters reuters said republicans ask
biden to end his divisive
policy on teaching black history it is
the most insane
propaganda i agree and this stuff has
been coming up in schools for a while i
think it's only recently though that
parents have been seeing it and that's
why people have been able to speak out
against it
oddly enough it's because of remote
schooling that parents were able to see
this stuff i know that that happened in
my house right so my son
kicked out of school march 16th with all
of the other 1.1 million school children
in new york city
and hardly any of them are back still i
think the uh we recently reopened sort
of
middle and high schools but it's there's
like 300 000 kids back in schools
basically the last
the last number that i checked um which
was maybe a month ago actually but um
once my son came home and i started
seeing what was going on in the
classroom
it wasn't really a big deal until after
george floyd was killed and then
i heard his teachers say that they were
going to have a day talking about
um i think it was a day talking about
uh white privilege um
and another day talking about uh
you know what happened and everything so
i set up my voice recorder
to just record what was going on on his
call
and i recorded hours of this
conversation
um where the white kids were basically
and
he was actually the only white kid in
the class so where
the white kids were basically told that
um
they didn't even know that there was
racism in their family that their
parents
didn't know that they were racist that
their grandparents didn't know that they
were racist and i'm looking at our
family and i'm sure lots of parents did
this as well
my son's grandmother was a public
defender in philadelphia she defended
move members i don't know if you guys
know who that is she defended um
you want you want to briefly describe oh
so move was a black nationalist
organization
they were in west philadelphia they were
targeted by
the fbi and the city they were
eventually bombed in this horrible
situation i think it was
85 maybe um they were bombed by a black
mayor who teamed up with the fbi
uh and um so that's what is that your
mom who definitely no no that
is my son's um dad's mom
yeah and defended the movement she
defended yeah i believe she defended
eddie africa
wow uh yeah but the teacher said that
this is this is a racist person this
racist family
um my grandmother was a public school
teacher in brownsville
brooklyn in the 40s her parents were
immigrants
but i mean it doesn't it doesn't even
matter what your background is
right i mean the idea that a teacher
should be telling you that your
grandparents are probably racist and
that they don't know it and that you
don't know it and that this is just the
passed down legacy through your family
on the basis of your skin color is
absurd
that a teacher should be telling a kid
that anything is a product
of skin color or race
is completely anathema to the civil
rights movement that is
that is what should be being taught
right
you know what's really funny about
critical race theory when you look up
the wikipedia for it
they have to define what white supremacy
means because it doesn't mean what
people think it means
so it actually says crt is loosely
unified by two common themes first that
white supremacy exists and maintains
power through the law
they then add in parentheses after white
supremacy societal racism
right because in the language of the
cult members when they say white
supremacy they don't mean what 98
percent of
americans understand it to be that a
white supremacist is somebody
who believes white people are superior
or supreme they've just
changed it to be now just objectivity
and right history and being on time
being on time as white supremacist
um yeah i think it's sort of interesting
too because the new definition of white
supremacy means that there can be
no um way to educate yourself out of it
there's no way to have forgiveness
there's no reconciliation at all it's
just it's a permanent condition
until you know and looking at something
like systemic racism
basically the entire society needs to be
dismantled before that can be
repaired and we're looking at a you know
set of theories that
the people who support them the idea
would be you have to dismantle society
but they're not offering any anything to
rebuild it on
right it's just a completely destructive
idea
i agree and i often refer to it as a
chaotic and destructive force
because there's no real rules like is
women offensive today because you've got
to say wymixon but then whimxen is
offensive because it excludes certain
women
and i think maybe the reality is there
may be competing interests
in terms of what comes next the one
thing they all agree on is destroy the
system
destroy the system but i do think many
of those who say who claim to be trained
marxists
don't want to tell you what their actual
solution is
because people would revolt if they
found out what these people were
planning
and so they say we got to tear down
white supremacy and everyone goes that
sounds pretty good to me
and then first of all they don't mean
literal white supremacy they mean some
ridiculous
nonsensical term they say we're
anti-racist which doesn't mean not
racist doesn't mean that racism
literally means be racist and then they
say diverse which
also is just another you know diversity
inclusivity and equity
are just more buzz words that don't
really make a lot of sense and then
that's the halfway right after they
burned all to the ground
what they want is probably you know
moral authoritarianism
they have control they can have whatever
they want you go live in the gutter i
think that's really interesting too
and i think conservatives pushed away
from
having any sort of moral compass after
the
90s christian right takeover
of congress with newt gingrich and all
of those guys and
the conservatives were pretty well
slammed at that point for
having a moral perspective and having it
be a christian moral perspective and
having that be
oppressive and the wrong thing to do and
after that conservatives embraced
um relativism in a very real way
uh you know the liberals were embracing
relativism
anything you do is fine if that's what
you want to do which to a certain extent
you know
there's nothing for it people are going
to do what they want to do whether you
want to judge them for it or not
but the conservatives left a vacuum
of moral authority and of moral
perspective
and it's been filled with something that
has actually
no um no basis
right so if you look at for example a
relig let's take a religious moral
perspective
you could have the ten commandments in
there right that could be a basis upon
which you're making determinations you
could use the beatitudes and the gospel
according to matthew as a basis to make
determinations which is basically
be really kind you guys right but when
we look at
the contemporary leftist um
moral framework framework there's no
foundation
there's no basis i agree so it's just
this shifting sands of a value system
that is whatever you want it to be
whenever you want it to be it so long as
you can use it to maintain your own
power it's like a hologram
yeah it's it's like it's like a hologram
of a religion right i was reading this
book a long time ago i don't know how
true any of this stuff is it was like a
book on quantum physics
and they talked about how the the
chemical properties of an element and
this is probably
your alley a chemical property of an
element is based on the amount of
electrons is that
like you know so hydrogen is one helium
is two yeah and so they said something
interesting happened when they were
working on circuit boards
when an electron got trapped in
you know this one part of the board
where there's i'm probably totally
ruining
this concept maybe you guys listening
understand what this is i was reading a
book this is like 10 years ago
they said they were sending electrons
through you know pathways in a circuit
board
and they had they had an area where
basically the electron got stuck in a
you know small space and it began to
orbit nothing but it began to
uh represe exude the chemical properties
of hydrogen with no nucleus
oh interesting and so i think about that
again more of ian's alley in this regard
but it's it's it's it's vaguely similar
in that
that's what that's what i feel like we
have with critical race theory it's
missing the nucleus core component of a
real moral framework
like you can disagree with religions and
what these people believe but there's
like as you mentioned a foundation to
where these ideas come from how they've
persisted this long bad ideas go away
good ideas remain become stronger
and then you look at woke and it's
hollow well it's because there's no
there's no synthesis right there's only
woke there's only
this this critical race system or this
gender critical
you know um not gender critical that's
a little bit there's that critical
theory critical theory
let me point something out real quick
too i am partly bothered by how many
people just keep saying critical race
theory over and over again
ignoring critical gender theory that's
part of it too critical theory as a
whole critical theory
and the problem is that because of the
way that it's constructed in society
you can broach these ideas but you can't
broach any opposition to them because if
you broach opposition to them
then there's something wrong with you
and you are you know a racist or
transphobic or whatever the other things
are that you could be labeled you're a
bigot in some
sense of the word um but unless these
critical theories are challenged there's
no synthesis to the better idea
they just stand there on their own and
they need to be challenged we need to
challenge
every idea that we have and we need to
be challenging our ideas all the time
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time